well i think if you again and this is
just only a somewhat provincial view
then there was a period in my own
discipline of infectious diseases back
in the late 19th century when people
were just starting to appreciate the
germ theory of disease like instead of
the historical components that we have
these plagues we have these influenzas
we have cholera we have this we have no
idea where it comes from there were a
group of people Louis Pasteur coke all
of the group from the altitude past or
the German group metchnikoff and others
who were able to take a field that was
completely bare bones and no one had any
idea what was going on to actually make
those first initial discoveries that a
microbe actually caused tuberculosis you
can actually take that microbe you could
you could inject it into someone or into
an animal and you could create the
disease that you once thought was just
some humors from heaven that caused it
so the heroes and the people that I look
up to with those people who struggled
against a complete vast unknown right
now there's so much known in science
that when I and my colleagues do it
although we occasionally make
transforming discoveries we're standing
on the shoulders of giants who didn't
have what we had a hundred or so years
ago when they made those phenomenal
discoveries